so fun to talk about Healthcare in a
past tense we've done it like so many
people you know in this industry talk
about oh we're gonna do this and we're
gonna do this and all it would be really
cool if we did this we've done it we had
our first event where all of our
Fighters have health insurance that now
they're going into their second Camp you
know we have sound bite after sound bite
of them being like I feel so much more
confident to go hard in the in the
training camp because they're covered
there and then also what's really
different is it's a fighter owned League
you know these Fighters they got their
shares after their ceremonial weigh-in
like hey you fought in this first event
you're gonna be taken care of forever
with it obviously shares for one event
is lower than if you're with us for
years and years and years sure but it'll
take care of you as much as you put into
it